Olympians have been bending (and occasionally
breaking) the rules in an effort to give themselves
an edge over the competition since the games
began.
Despite this, the International Olympic Committee
(IOC) only started testing for performance
enhancing substances in 1968, and only seem
to have really started taking the issue seriously
in the 1990s.
As for the 1968 Games, despite that a large
percentage of Olympians are thought to have
been using performance enhancing drugs, they
only managed to catch and disqualify one guy.
What dangerous substance did he take to get
himself disqualified?
He drank two beers before an event, resulting
in him becoming the first person to be disqualified
for “doping”.
To really drive home how ingrained using performance
enhancers is in Olympic culture, and to highlight
how endemic is was before the IOC began to
crack down on it recently, ancient Olympians
were known to drink “potions” containing
mysterious, often exotic herbs, or even ground
up animal testicles, in the belief that doing
so would give them an edge.
Much like the athletes that wear colored tape
or more recently the use of cupping therapy,
it didn’t really matter if the thing actually
helped them- only that they thought it did.
Although there were no specific rules against
using performance enhancing substances back
then, there were rules in place against the
use of magic to “curse” or otherwise unnerve
an opponent.
In other words- in the ancient Olympics, you
were free to use anything you wished to improve
your own performance, but you weren’t allowed
to try and negatively impact the performance
of others.
As far as we can tell, this didn’t actually
stop people from doing such things.
When the Olympic Games were revived in the
19th century, athletes were similarly open
to having various substances put into their
bodies if it had even a small chance at giving
them the ability to perform citius, altius,
fortius.
For example, Thomas Hicks, the winner of the
1904 Olympic Marathon was given doses of strychnine
and shots of brandy in the middle of the race
by his trainers in full view of gathered crowds
and officials.
At the time, strychnine was used in small
doses as a performance enhancing drug.
Anything but small doses would, of course,
kill the athlete via asphyxiation due to paralysis
of the respiratory muscles.
However, if the dose wasn’t too large, strychnine
was believed to provide a performance boost
via the muscle spasms it relatively quickly
induces.
They gave Hicks three doses during the race…
This was only part of the way in which his
trainers almost killed him.
You see, while his trainers were willing to
give him, essentially, rat poison and brandy,
they refused to give him any water despite
the sweltering Missouri summer heat.
By the end of the race, Hicks was delusional
and had to more or less be carried to and
over the finish line as he was too weak to
remain upright on his own.
He immediately passed out upon finishing and
the doctor was unable to revive him for almost
a full hour.
Despite not being able to finish the race
without help, he was nevertheless declared
the victor.
And if you thought that being carried over
the finish line made for a questionable victory,
Hicks only won after it emerged that the first
person to finish, Fred Lorz, had traversed
most of the course by car.
You see, due to the amazingly bad conditions
in the race, Lorz decided to quit and hitched
a ride back to the starting point.
When he exited the car and subsequently jogged
back into view of the spectators, everyone
just assumed he’d ran the whole thing, so
he went along with it.
Eventually his automotive adventure came to
light, at which point he claimed his pretending
he ran had all been a joke.
Back to doping in the Olympics.
The IOC didn’t officially ban certain dangerous
performance enhancing substances until the
late 1960s, and even then, it took the death
of an athlete to jar them into taking a stand.
That athlete was a cyclist competing in the
1960 games on behalf of Denmark called Knud
Enemark Jensen.
He collapsed and subsequently died in the
middle of a race, with it widely reported
that the cause of his collapse was that he’d
been given a cocktail of drugs, including
Roniacol, by his trainer beforehand.
Of course, it should also be noted that at
the time it was 108° F (42° C) out and what
actually happened was that Jensen succumbed
to heat stroke and then fractured his skull
after falling off his bike- the official cause
of death was brain injury resultant from his
fractured skull.
Although it was ultimately determined that
drugs probably didn’t have anything to do
with Jensen’s death, the IOC was shaken
enough by the media backlash to decide to
ban, at least officially (more on this in
a bit), certain substances starting in the
1968 Games.
Although testing was in effect during the
1968 Winter Olympics in Grenoble, France,
no athlete is known to have been caught with
a performance enhancing drug in their system.
The same couldn’t be said for that year’s
summer games.
(At the time the Winter and Summer Olympics
occurred in the same year) During those Olympics,
as mentioned, Swedish athlete Hans-Gunnar
Liljenwall was found to have alcohol in his
system.
Though alcohol may seem like the exact opposite
of a dangerous performance enhancing drug
given that it dulls the senses, clouds judgement,
and is otherwise pretty safe in moderation,
in the right quantities, there was, and still
is, a popular idea that it gives one an advantage.
How?
The hypothesis goes that in skill based games
that rely more on muscle memory than things
like reaction times- games like darts, billiards
and even target shooting- alcohol could, perhaps,
potentially improve performance in individuals
prone to stress or “overthinking“.
Whether actually helpful or not, in Liljenwall’s
case, he was trying to use the alcohol for
this very purpose and so drank two beers before
a shooting event to steady his nerves, and
hopefully hands.
After his urine was found to contain alcohol,
Liljenwall was disqualified and was ordered
to return the bronze pentathlon medal he’d
won while under the influence.
Not stopping there, the rest of Sweden’s
pentathletes were also forced to hand back
their medals for Liljenwall’s mistake.
What makes Liljenwall’s disqualification
even more bizarre is that, seemingly, little
was actually being done to stop anyone else
from using performance enhancing drugs.
You see, they only used urine tests during
the 1968 games out of fear that blood tests
could potentially spread infection or cause
some sort of injury to the athletes.
Although today urine tests are fairly comprehensive
and accurate for many things, back then the
science was still in its infancy and the chemists
performing the tests were only looking for
a very specific set of substances, mostly
“hard drugs” like cocaine and heroin,
but not steroids.
In fact, in 1969, an American weightlifter
responded to being asked about the recent
ban on amphetamine use by defiantly saying,
“What ban?”
He went on to explain that he and his fellow
athletes had all used a new drug recently
developed in West Germany that couldn’t
be detected during the previous Olympic games,
openly bragging: “When they get a test for
that one, we’ll find something else.
It’s like cops and robbers.”
Beyond some using undetectable drugs, others
would use a catheter to fill their bladder
with someone else’s urine directly before
testing.
Women had another trick up their, well…
not sleeves… in the use of a condom filled
with clean urine cleverly hidden inside the
vagina.
Because the IOC was only testing urine and
the tests were fairly inaccurate and not very
sensitive on the whole, more low-tech methods
of avoiding detection included drinking a
lot of water to dilute results beyond the
capabilities of the testing of the age to
detect anything in, or simply rejecting the
test results for various reasons.
For instance, in a non-Olympic event at the
1970 Weightlifting World Championship in Ohio,
all three medalists were found to have banned
substances in their urine.
Despite this, they were allowed to keep their
winning medals.
Why?
Due to systemic issues with testing procedures,
with some athletes even managing to get around
being tested at all, including the guys who
came in fourth, fifth and sixth place at this
event, there was no way to ensure the medals
would definitely go to someone who hadn’t
cheated.
Given that the orginisation knew well that
pretty much all of the top lifters were using
drugs, they reasoned the winner should probably
just be the best of the cheaters.
This same problem plagued the Olympics as
well.
Dr. Robert Voy, formerly in charge of drug
testing for the U.S. Olympic Committee, noted
that, beyond inherent problems with the accuracy
of the tests, complete lack of quality control
in the samples, and inconsistent procedures
from test to test, because the tests were
so easily fooled, those in charge of the drug
testing resorted to “a less libelous approach
to testing called ‘sink testing,’ used
to prevent false positive reporting and legal
challenges.
This now nonexistent method meant all samples
were collected but either were not tested
or were simply poured down the drain.”
Dr. Voy went on to state, “The athletes
knew better than anyone that the drug testing
posed little threat to them.
They scoffed at testing notices and went right
on with their routine drug use with little
fear of detection.”
In fact, one survey of track and field athletes
from seven different nations in the 1972 Olympics
revealed that a whopping 61% of them admitted
to using steroids before those games.
The actual number of track athletes using
is thought to have been higher as presumably
not everyone taking steroids would be so keen
on admitting it, even in an informal survey.
The reason they could be so flippant, particularly
about using steroids was that, while drugs
like alcohol, heroin, and cocaine were being
tested for, as previously mentioned, at this
points steroids were not.
On top of that, even if they tested positive
for substances that were being tested for,
they could simply say their sample wasn’t
handled or tested right, which may well have
been true.
Other excuses included things like- if they’d
been using heroin, they could say they’d
been eating poppy seed muffins, and even could
be publicly seen doing so to back their story.
(And yes, that is really a thing, even today
It would not be until the late 1980s when
Canadian sprinter Ben Johnson stunned the
world by setting a new world record- 9.79
seconds- in the 100m sprint, and subsequently
had his medal stripped three days later after
testing positive for stanozolol, that the
public began to wake up to the problem.
Beyond Johnson, there was evidence that six
of the eight sprinters in that race were likely
using steroids.
This was a problem in the sport that famed
Olympian Carl Lewis (who finished 9.92 seconds
in that sprint) raged against in the media
before the 1988 games, noting “There are
gold medalists at this meet who are on drugs,
that [100 metres] race will be looked at for
many years, for more reasons than one.”
Funny enough, Johnson’s trainer, Charlie
Francis, would later come out and say the
fact that Johnson tested positive for stanozolol
just showed the flaws in the Olympic testing
procedures.
You see, Johnson was actually taking the steroid
furazabol, as he didn’t like the way stanozolol
made him feel.
Francis also claimed that at the time all
the top athletes in the sport were taking
steroids.
In support of Francis’ assertions, in a
recent CBC documentary, Ben Johnson: A Hero
Disgraced, a former IOC official revealed
that approximately 80% of the track and field
athletes in the 1988 Games showed significant
signs of long-term steroid abuse.
Not only that, but 20 actually tested positive
but were nevertheless cleared for the Games
by the IOC.
It has been claimed that the reason the IOC
was so keen on allowing these athletes to
compete was due to pressure from NBC who didn’t
want the games to “collapse in scandal”.
They were also supposedly refusing to pay
the IOC owed funds and threatening to withdraw
broadcasting the Olympics that year if such
a thing happened before the Games.
The media frenzy that surrounded Johnson’s
rapid downfall, along with the public becoming
aware of the widespread use of steroids in
the Olympics, resulted in the IOC finally
putting significant effort into ending performance
enhancing drug use among Olympics athletes.
In the end, when one’s very livelihood is
on the line and said individual has such a
small window of opportunity for success, from
the original Olympics to modern times, athletes
have always sought to gain any advantage whatsoever
they can find, even today often resorting
to pseudoscience like colored tape or cupping
therapy.
Unfortunately for those that play within the
rules, for some, ignoring them for the chance
of a podium and the financial windfall that
comes with it is sometimes seen as worth the
risk of getting caught.
The aforementioned idea that alcohol can improve
performance in sporting events is jokingly
called the “Optimal Altered State Theory”.
It basically posits that every person has
an optimal state of drunkenness at which they’re
able to perform better at certain tasks than
they would while sober.
As you might imagine, there is little in the
way of hard evidence supporting this hypothesis,
but who doesn’t know someone who has claimed,
“I play better when I’m drunk!”